benjamin netanyahu's long-time
leadership of israel
could be about to end in the last hour
right-wing leader naftali bennett
said he's joining a coalition with the
main centrist leader yad lapid
after four inconclusive elections in two
years the final deadline
is coming up on wednesday to make the
coalition deal a reality well our
diplomatic editor james bayes is live
from west jerusalem james there's been a
lot of speculation
swirling around these talks that have
been going on just bring us up to date
with what's been going on
well dramatic developments in israeli
politics the long
reign of benjamin netanyahu may now
be very close to an end and it's
certainly looking that way
after naftali bennett a right-wing
politician said he was going to join a
coalition
that has been formed by the center-left
politician
yeah lapid the two men have come to a
deal
and the deal uh many thought of this
coalition depended on mr bennett being
the king maker but it looks like the
deal actually also involves him becoming
initially at least the king
because under the deal mr bennett will
be the first prime minister
and then it will rotate to mr lapid at a
later stage
it's almost a done deal but not yet
remember there are more than two parties
involved in this coalition and all of
them i think all of the deals have to be
absolutely confirmed with all the
coalition members
and then the next stage is that mr lapid
who was asked to form a coalition goes
back to israel's president
to say that he's managed to form a
government
we've heard as i just said from mr
bennett uh in the last
hour uh much of the criticism of him has
been that he
is joining this very broad coalition
that involves left-wing parties
he made the point though addressing the
israeli people that this
new government if he was able to form it
was going to be even more right-wing
than the current one we've also heard in
the last few minutes from benjamin
netanyahu the current prime minister the
long-serving prime minister
and he said that um mr bennett had uh
not lived up to his election promises uh
by doing a deal with
left-wing parties so a great deal of
controversy
a great deal of of accusations by all
the key players but particularly from
prime minister netanyahu
who may well be losing his grip on power
benjamin netanyahu placed himself right
at the center of the recent israeli
action that we saw against palestinians
when
members of hamas were firing rockets
into israel and israeli military was
firing missiles
into gaza the question is of course
about the
the ceasefire that we're only days into
at the moment
is there any indication that should
benjamin netanyahu step
down what the relationship between
israel and the palestinians is likely to
be
well if mr netanyahu is no longer prime
minister it's now looking pretty certain
that it'll be mr bennett
who is the first prime minister of this
new
change coalition government let me tell
you about
naftali bennett and his policies towards
the palestinians in his own personal
views
he is opposed to a two-state solution he
is opposed to a palestinian state he is
opposed to any restriction
on settlements that puts him completely
against the agreed
international uh position the position
of u.n security council resolutions the
position of the
quartet of key players on the middle
east
but and there's a very big but here as i
said to you before
his coalition if he does finally get to
form it and it's looking likely now
will include parties from a broad
cross-section of israeli politics
including left-wing parties
and so i don't think they're going to be
able to do anything with regard to the
palestinian issue because they disagree
on it and so i think what is most likely
is that this will be a new government
that will deal with all the other
issues facing israel but not do anything
significant on the palestinian issue and
that in some ways
might rather match the biden
administration's approach yes
they want to improve the lives of
ordinary palestinians they talking about
rebuilding gaza
but they're not planning to launch any
face-to-face negotiations between
israelis and palestinians
in the past few years james it certainly
seemed to those of us looking on from
outside the benjamin netanyahu has been
fighting increasingly hard to keep his
grip on power
this is more than just politics for
benjamin netanyahu though isn't it
his future should he be forced out
for us to step down from office could be
radically different talk us through what
the possible implications are for him
well for benjamin netanyahu and for
israel this is
if he is out going to be the end of an
era because he has been
the longest-serving prime minister of
this country this time around he's been
in power
for 13 years so it marks a big moment
for the country
for the prime minister himself after
that length of time in power and
remember he was also prime minister in
the 1990s it will be a big big
change he's not leaving politics if he
does uh
no longer uh end up as prime minister he
will be the opposition leader and leader
of lacude which is still the largest
party but as you say he is also facing
corruption charges
and many believe that having the office
of prime minister being the incumbent
was beneficial in terms of fighting
those corruption charges so
he i think if it if what is seems to be
happening
and we don't have it absolutely we don't
haven't got to the stage of the
president
um meeting and saying that the new
government can be formed but if it is
if he is losing power then it's losing
power politically but potentially also
um affecting him legally too james
thanks very much indeed that's james
baze our diplomatic editor talking to us
from west jerusalem